starting this weekend in the german
alpine resort of el mao leaders of the
g7 will meet
they've invited extra guests to
participate including indian prime
minister modi underscoring the country's
growing geostrategic role in the world
here at dw we've been working on a
series looking at india's rise it's
called india's dilemma and you'll find
it on our dw news youtube page here's a
quick look
india finds itself in a dramatic
geopolitical squeeze
russia its old friend and arm supplier
is deepening ties with china
weakened by the war and becoming
subservient to a power that's no friend
to india
there are serious concerns in new delhi
about whether russia will continue to be
a reliable supplier
at the same time china's threat to india
becomes ever more apparent
compelling india to reinforce its
borders against attempts to take its
territory
the chinese are breathing down our
borders and they just killed our
soldiers less than two years ago
delhi faces deep dilemmas over how close
to get to the west
the us has had many many alliances not
all of them have fared very well
india has a long tradition of avoiding
close alliances and preferring to stay
non-aligned but the war is forcing it to
think again about all of its
relationships
and face up to some choices
it hasn't had to make before
in part one of this video we'll look at
how durable india's old friendship with
russia really is
and whether it can survive moscow's new
path
the russia relationship is now in a
position
where it really does need to be
rethought in part two we'll see how
tensions between india and china
are far more dangerous than the rest of
the world realizes
think about this
beijing even says that it should control
an entire indian state
after russia's invasion of ukraine
it's all too easy to imagine a
devastating war
so we are talking about
a face big section of the world a very
important part of the world are very
large armies nuclear armed countries
fighting fighting for each other
and in part three we'll ask whether
india and the west can really come
together
or if they're ultimately heading in very
different directions
when china attacked us
where was this degree of outrage from
europe or from other countries india is
coming to resemble russia and china far
more than it resembles western
democracies so as the world enters this
dangerous new era
india could be the deciding factor so no
matter where you are in the world the
choices made here in delhi
matati be sure to go online and catch
the full series and we have richard
walker chief international editor and
the series correspondent with us um
richard let's talk about india and this
upcoming g7 summit and i want to start
by playing a clip from u.s president joe
biden
i think that the relationship between
india and the united states
the largest democracies in the world
is destined to be stronger
closer
and tighter and i think he can benefit
the whole world
right and then i want to play a clip
from shashi tha or indian
parliamentarian and former diplomat
would i want india to publicly declare
itself an ally of a country i'm not even
sure i'm ready to bite that bullet
because
the word alliance
implies to some degree a mortgaging of
your freedom to make your own decisions
so it sounds like the two countries are
talking past each other yeah it can
sometimes seem like that melissa i mean
you certainly get a strong sense from
the americans and on my recent trip to
delhi uh i got this very strongly that
they would like to tie india closer into
the kind of western-led sort of what
they see as an alliance kind of liberal
democracies um you know which is really
sort of girding up for this sort of
pushback against the autocracies of
china and russia
and you do often get this sense that
india is sort of going along with it to
some extent but playing almost like hard
to get in some ways
and there are historical reasons for
that like india has this very long
history since independence of
non-alignment not wanting to throw all
of its eggs in one basket with any one
country so trying to sort of stress in
what the kind of language they talk
about now is wanting like the world to
be multi-polar that they don't want to
kind of get dragged into a sort of new
cold war uh sort of scenario but the
americans certainly trying to coax them
in with you know formats like the quad
you know this regional grouping in asia
with the americans with japan uh with
australia and india trying to sort of
say india you're a big democracy you
belong with us okay so they're part of
the quad uh but in terms of russia
though how
uh
to what extent will the leaders of the
g7 be able to convince india to reorient
its policy well certainly india's been
under a lot of pressure already to try
to put some distance between itself and
russia over the the war uh that russia
has launched in ukraine um india has
really pretty steady or right from the
beginning being clear that or trying to
take what they see is a kind of
principled independent position of
saying that um they do they call for a
ceasefire that they condemn violence um
but not really coming out and really
really making a break with russia for
instance at the united nations uh in the
united nations security council just
after the war began um they famously uh
did not vote against the russians
they abstained right um and
the indian message back on russia to
some extent to the west is sort of just
don't lecture us
um and there are various different
angles to that partly you know people
will say well it's the west that's been
starting wars in the last 20 years what
are you uh lecturing us about um
what's so different about this one also
on energy uh with you know western
countries trying to tell india don't
start buying russian energy while we're
trying to to sanction it and the indians
say well we have a very poor population
we owe it to our population to get
energy as cheaply as we can
uh and there are some criticisms that
actually or or observations that india
is actually
much more closer politically
with russia and china yeah well this is
the other side of the story because on
the one hand the west is very keen to
bind india closer on the other hand
they're concerned about what's happening
in india
about the illiberal direction that
indian democracy is moving in and we
spoke to some critical voices also as
part of this film while we were in india
and maybe we can queue up a a sound bite
from hacho singh bal he's the political
editor of a prominent kind of
intellectual news magazine there
india is coming to resemble russia and
china far more than it resembles western
democracies so the west will have to
deal with this country through very
hard-nosed means rather than by thinking
that this common shared value of
constitutional democracy is going to
pull india
into our sphere that is not true
yeah so what achar singh baal is saying
there is that this this idea of the west
that is trying to appeal to india to
join this kind of democratic pushback of
sort on values basis against china and
russia
that that's not going to work because
india is maybe not moving in in this
kind of liberal direction that that
india has for instance there's very
severe criticism of india's treatment of
its muslim minorities
and
other concerns about the direction that
indian democracy is taking so very
interesting to see how this dynamic
between india and the west plays out
richard walker thank you so much for
joining us in the studio
you